The joe rogan experience.
I was influenced by a tell a massively,
yeah.
Drinking too that that oh no,
I was being thing.
No,
I was fine.
I told you I came in,
explained that because this is a crazy story.
You didn't say this on the podcast.
I have when I was in 1997,
Rollingstone magazine wrote a six and a half page article about me calling me
the number one party animal in the country.
It's actually gets a little weirder.
What are you doing?
Standup act,
just partying.
I had a notorious reputation of Florida state for being like funny,
but being a wild party animal.
Like what kind of Shit were you doing?
Just Fun Shit.
Like uh,
like fun.
I think Wa loudest guy in the room.
Shit.
You know like I remember we,
I used to climb up on this telephone pole outside the bars on Tennessee street.
There'll be 500 people out there and I just stand up my go.
Everyone shut the fuck up and listen.
If you want to smoke weed,
go to my house and the cops are all sitting there.
I have tons of weed enough for everybody and we're all gonna have a blast and
get eye.
If you know where I live.
You're invited.
If you don't ask someone,
just no one tell the fucking cops and you'd have literally 500 people just
giggling at the idea that someone was offering them weed in front of the cops
face.
And what are the cops saying when you did this?
They would laugh too.
Like one time for an election,
uh,
gotten naked for this election and just shit on a pizza box and won the election
election.
For what?
For my fraternity.
I just got up naked and shit on a pizza box and then everyone who won and then I
won.
Did you wipe?
Not just shit.
I just,
Shit.
I learned one very important lesson when you go number two,
you also go one,
cause I pissed all over the feet on everyone that was sitting in can't stop it
when you go one,
two.
And so I won the election.
So like all these stories came out and then rolling stones like let's do a
fucking,
let's do an article on him.
Oh my God,
it gets crazier.
Ready?
Sorry for the you already for the part that you go that you go bullshit.
I will never say bull shit.
I've heard enough of your stories.
I'm not so lost.
So uh,
so Oliver stone option the rights to my life and then from the article.
So then I try to stand up and I moved to New York to start to stand ups.
I did it once and to in a townhouse,
you know we went amazing.
I got offer my own morning show in Tallahassee.
Really?
Yeah.
Oliver Stone Officer.
The rights of my life,
like I start doing stand up five minutes later will Smith sees me to stand up
and I get a deal development deal with him like right out the gate.
It's like bill burr style,
like been doing standup for no time at all development deal based on the article
and that the fact that I could competently do standup somewhat and then the
development deal falls apart with Oliver Stone.
All the guys that have submitted their scripts for Oliver Stone's movie about my
life then get their intellectual property back.
One of the guy takes his movie changes,
my name sells at the National Lampoon and it becomes a movie Van Wilder.
So theoretically,
and I say this theoretically loosely,
I'll never be able to sue.
I'm never would sue,
I never would sue.
But I went into national lampoon and did,
do you remember Kevin Couch?
He used to have a show on national lampoon XM radio.
And I told him,
I said,
bring some exact sin.
I've always wanted to find out if this is true.
So then he brought some execs in and I start telling the story just like I am
you one of the guys fucking locks up.
Like hold on,
stop right now.
What do you want?
What's going on here is just like an ambush.
And I was like,
no,
I just want to be able to tell it on radio and no,
I'm not lying.
That's all I care about.
All I care about is the story being like true.
Right.
And,
and he was like,
what do you want?
Like your own radio show.
I'm like,
fine.
And then he's like,
we'll do a show parting with the original band.
While are you happy?
And I was like,
yeah.
And so then he was like,
pretty much,
I was like,
so I can say it's true.
But you were worried you were going to sue them.
They were worried I was going to sue them cause we put it must mean you have a
case.
Right?
Why don't you just go fucking sue those cunts?
Barry Katz said to me one,
they papa,
you can be one of two guys.
You can be the guy that's Susan doesn't work.
Or you can be the guy that doesn't soon works.
Which millimolar?
Yes.
[inaudible]
okay.
I never knew,
I never knew how to start.
I don't hear anything.
Brian.